so this is a great view that almost
looks like it's from the international
space station but no it is from our
camera on top of black mountain way down
in the southeast part of town uh when
there's not enough light during the
overnight hours the camera turns black
and white so what you don't see is this
blanket of cloud cover that's been
sitting on top of us uh since late
yesterday afternoon officially we're at
72 degrees before we get to neighborhood
temperatures we're going to show what we
call the future cast so this is not
actual radar this is a computer
projection of where clouds and radio be
so by eight o'clock not much going on
nine o'clock maybe gene picking up a
rain shower however by 11 looks like
henderson and the south valley will be
getting some rain these things are
moving very quickly though so that by
one o'clock in the afternoon nothing
going on maybe a sprinkle up around
lincoln county be getting some rain by
three o'clock this afternoon another
area of rain starting to form so that by
five o'clock more rain moving from the
south to the north that is the direction
of these storms certainly southwestern
utah northwestern arizona in for a lot
more rain than we're going to get right
now temperatures upper 60s for aleonte
everybody else still hanging on to the
70s because with a blanket of cloud
cover the heat from yesterday does not
radiate back up into the atmosphere it's
just kind of capped off we made it to 89
yesterday now to nevada and beyond 72
right now for death valley caliente and
mesquite you're definitely going to be
getting some rain boulder city probably
some showers cedar city for sure you're
going to get some rain near 54 right now
so we mentioned 89 the high yesterday
only going for 80 today our current
temperature is the low so far this
morning so hit and miss pop-up storms
got some lightning going on down there
thunderstorms east of the i-15 and north
of the i-40 trying to work their way up
here we'll see if how long they last
otherwise a fairly quiet day some
stronger storms over georgia your eight
day forecast back to sunshine and back
to the mid 80s 86 on thursday however
are going to have to put some wind on
there for friday because look at that
sharp temperature drop from thursday to
friday with another chance for rain